[Music]
at the UN General Assembly this week the
US and Russia pointed fingers at one
another for the devastating war in Syria
and the resulting refugee crisis Obama
took a subtle jab at Putin's defense of
the Syrian government saying in
accordance with this logic we should
support tyrants like Bashar al-assad who
drops barrel bombs to Massacre innocent
children because the alternative is
surely worse Obama's kind of right about
Russia the country has sent tanks and
aircrafts as well as military advisers
to beef up as its defenses but the US is
by no means an innocent bystander
weapons US supply to rebel opposition
groups in Syria have inadvertently ended
up in the hands of al Qaeda and in Iraq
weapons meant for the Iraqi army ended
up in the hands of Isis in fact the US
happens to be the biggest arms supplier
in the world the US has supplied
countries like Israel Saudi Arabia and
Egypt with complex weapon systems even
as their governments have been blamed
for committing human rights abuses with
those weapons the thing is the weapons
industry is big business worth eighty
five billion dollars worldwide US
companies including Lockheed Martin and
Boeing sold more than 20 3.7 billion
dollars in arms last year to nearly 100
different countries and arms exports
have actually increased under Obama by
23% the most of any administration since
World War two the majority of US weapons
exports end up in Asia and Oceania
although the Middle East received 32% of
all exports in 2014 and because domestic
sales have declined in recent years US
companies have all the more reason to
look abroad
earlier this year Lockheed Martin CEO
Marilyn Hewson said that the company is
looking at the quote volatility in both
the Middle East and Asia Pacific as a
way to increase their sales
internationally in both of those regions
which are growth areas for us we expect
that there's going to continue to be
opportunities for us to bring our
capabilities to them in other words the
more war
the more profit
now Congress does control the export of
us-made weapons but the defense industry
keeps Congress on their side with 150
million dollars in campaign
contributions and lobbying last year
alone
Pope Francis even called out the u.s.
during a recent speech to Congress he
said the reason deadly weapons are being
sold to groups and governments around
the world is simply for money money that
is drenched in blood often innocent
blood so is the business of war worth
the profit when you consider the human
cost
[Music]